Traductor: Florencia Batalla
Revisor: Paula Motter
(Aplausos)
Ustedes...
¿me están viendo?
Audiencia: ¡Sí!
Ok.
¿Me están mirando?
Audiencia: ¡Sí!
Ojalá haya habido alguna duda
entre una respuesta y la otra.
Porque no da lo mismo ver que mirar.
Les propongo una pequeña
experiencia. Cortita.
No es obligatoria. Los que tengan ganas.
Busquen al que tengan más cerca
y sosténganle la mirada unos segundos.
No pasa nada.
(Risas)
Bueno.
Obviamente, no les voy a preguntar
si pasó algo entre ustedes...
(Risas)
pero me muero de curiosidad.
Tengo casi la certeza de que algo pasó,
porque, insisto, no es
lo mismo ver que mirar.
Ver es una cuestión del ojo,
es cuestión del "yo".
Yo veo que acá hay mucha gente,
que hay hombres, que hay
mujeres, que hay familias,
que hay luces.
Cuando miro, miro con todo mi ser...
con todo mi ser.
Por eso cuando un grupo
de turistas, por ejemplo,
está frente al mismo paisaje,
solo a algunos se les escapa un lagrimón.
¡Principito, parece que tenías razón!
Lo esencial es invisible a los ojos.
¿Qué problema tiene la mirada?
Uno, fundamental: de mi mirada, nada sé.
Si alguien te pregunta:
"¿Por qué me mirás así?".
"¿Y cómo te miro?".
No lo sé.
Si voy a un espejo a buscar eso,
en el espejo me encuentro con los ojos.
La mirada la perdí en el camino.
Porque la mirada se construye
siempre en el encuentro con el otro.
Por eso, tantas historias de amor
empiezan con la mirada, ¿o no?
"Chicos, conocí a alguien
y no saben cómo me miró".
(Risas)
"Me va a hablar, me va a hablar".
¡Y cuántas historias de amor terminan
antes de que el otro te diga
que no te quiere más!
Pero en su mirada encontrás la nada misma.
Es que la mirada tiene elementos
inconscientes, inmanejables.
No la puedo construir.
Prueben, si esta noche
tienen un sábado prometedor,
ensayar una mirada sexy.
(Risas)
Prueben entrar a sus casas y decir:
"Quiero tener una mirada
de padre o madre Ingalls",
y resulta que estoy viviendo
como los Adams o como los Simpson.
(Risas)
Prueben, los docentes, hacer
una mirada Pichimahuida.
(Risas)
No sale, si es que perdí
la vocación docente...
o si es que nunca la tuve.
Vivimos mirando y siendo mirados,
vivimos convocando miradas.
"¡Mirame cuando te hablo!",
le dice un padre enojado a su hijo.
La docente al borde
de un ataque de nervios:
"¡Chicos, si no me miran,
cómo me van a atender!".
Una docente que intentaba
sorprender a los alumnos,
el día que yo fui, tenía un casco
blanco con luces intermitentes.
(Risas)
¡Así daba Matemáticas!
Y pregunté: "¿Viene siempre con casco?".
"No, no. ¡Tiene pelucas de todos colores!".
(Risas)
Y yo dije: "¡Qué vocación!".
Algún marido con plata, quizás,
que le compra las pelucas.
Son carísimas.
Pero después pensé: "Hace
ese esfuerzo para ser mirada, o vista".
Quizás mirada.
De ahí a que sea atendida,
hace falta un paso más,
hace falta proponer algo interesante.
Yo fui docente 33 años,
y me pasaron cosas con la mirada,
más de dos veces.
Y en eso soy muy freudiana.
Aprendí con Freud que cuando algo
te pasa más de dos veces
lo tenés que analizar.
¿Qué me pasaba?
Coloquio de fin de año,
se recibían de psicopedagogas conmigo.
Un excelente examen, un diez.
Y cuando terminaba,
firmaba la libreta y les decía:
"¿Por qué no participaron
en clase si sabían tanto?
¿Por qué se guardaron este saber?
¿Por qué no lo compartieron
con sus compañeros?".
"No, profe. Yo en marzo
le hice una pregunta
y Ud. me miró de una manera que yo
nunca más me animé a preguntar".
Guau.
Herida a la vocación docente.
Entonces mis clases a veces empezaban así:
"Chicos, hola. Soy Liliana.
Tengo ojos grandes.
(Risas)
Soy hipotiroidea.
Parece que mis ojos son muy decidores.
Y cada tanto paralizan a alguien
que se queda sin hacer preguntas,
y Uds., futuras psicopedagogas,
no se lo pueden permitir.
Al lado del instituto hay un barcito
que justamente se llama 'Psico Bar',
¿qué tal si tomamos un café y hablamos
de lo que nos pasa con las miradas?".
Porque Uds., futuras psicopedagogas,
van a pasarse la vida mirando pacientes,
padres, familias, escuelas,
docentes, directivos,
y no se pueden dar el lujo
de paralizar con la mirada.
Mucho menos que
se les suspendan las preguntas.
Porque cuando uno se deja
de preguntar, deja de aprender.
Y un psicopedagogo que deja
de aprender, es como raro, ¿no?
Porque nuestra disciplina se ocupa de eso.
Vivimos mirando, vivimos siendo mirados.
La tecnología empezó
a entrar en nuestras vidas.
Y ahí algo pasó.
Así como les dije recién que no
pueden construir una mirada,
lo que les quiero decir es
que las miradas construyen subjetividad.
Impactan en el sujeto.
No da lo mismo que un bebé
se encuentre al nacer
con una mirada amorosa de mamá
que le transmite el amor por la mirada.
Porque si le dice varias veces "te quiero"
el bebé no entiende nada porque no tiene
un universo lingüístico ni simbólico
para entender que el "te quiero"
es el amor, y la mirada lo atraviesa.
¿Qué pasará con estos bebés
que se encuentran con mamás
que no pueden dejar de ver los celulares
o las pantallas mientras dan de mamar?
¿Qué pasará con estos niños
que están almorzando
con el Sapo Pepe, con Peppa Pig,
con pantallas y no con miradas amorosas
de padres que se ponen felices
cuando comen toda la papilla?
O padres que pueden dejar la pantalla
para escuchar cómo les va en la vida,
en el patio, en el aula o con los amigos.
¿Qué pasará con estas familias
que han dejado hackear el diálogo
y la comunicación entre ellos
porque no pueden ni almorzar
ni cenar sin pantallas?
¿Qué pasará con las escuelas
que no se animan a romper filas?
Queridos docentes, ¡rompamos filas!
Si no, pasan de las pantallas
a la nuca de los compañeros.
Sentémonos en mesas
para que hagan trabajos cooperativos,
que investiguen, que se miren,
que se escuchen, que se conozcan,
que aprendan de la diversidad,
de esa diversidad que se pone en juego
en cualquier mesa de trabajo en una aula.
Nuestros chicos nacieron
y los estaba esperando la tecnología.
Yo no creo que nacieron nativos digitales.
No hay pruebas para saber
que nacieron nativos digitales.
Sí sé que nacieron en una sociedad
que los esperaba con las pantallas
desde muy chiquititos.
Y los chicos de todo
el mundo han querido tener
lo que ven en la mano de sus padres.
La tecnología es
una herramienta maravillosa.
Llegó para quedarse.
Tendremos cada vez más,
pero siempre que esté usada
a favor del ser humano.
No siempre es así.
Y ¿saben qué?
No conozco ninguna herramienta tecnológica
que le dé sentido a la vida.
Si no, no tendríamos
tantos suicidios adolescentes.
El sentido de la vida se encuentra
con un turismo interno,
buscando adentro de uno mismo.
"¿Para qué vine al mundo?".
"¿Qué quiero ser?".
"¿Qué quiero hacer?".
Y eso no me lo da la tecnología.
Es un viaje con muchas estaciones
y en cada estación siempre hay un "otro",
o unos cuantos "otros".
Y ojalá ahí aparezcan
las coordenadas del amor.
¡Ojalá!
Porque de no aparecer,
el camino es hacia la soledad.
Y los psiquiatras nos dicen
que la mayor causa de depresión,
a cualquier edad, es la soledad.
El hombre no nació para estar solo.
Lo dijo Dios, ¿no?
En una de esas le arruinó
la vida a Adán... pero dijo:
"No es bueno que el hombre esté solo",
y ahí aparecimos las Evas.
Pero el sentido de la vida
hay que encontrarlo
adentro de uno mismo.
Adentro de uno mismo, en ese viaje
que les estoy proponiendo,
donde las herramientas
tecnológicas no nos ayudan.
Nos ayuda el otro,
el encuentro con el otro,
el encuentro humano con el otro.
La verdad, me da pena ver niños solos.
Me dan pena pacientitos que se quejan
de la soledad en el aula, en el recreo,
de que no suena el teléfono
los fines de semana
para juntarse en un momento de amistad.
Y esa es nuestra deuda
que tenemos nosotros con la infancia,
y quiero compartirla con Uds.
Pero les quiero dejar esa deuda
y al mismo tiempo una estrategia
que aprendí de la mano de un hombre
con una mirada impresionante:
Eduardo Galeano, el escritor uruguayo.
¡Qué mirada y qué voz!
En ese cuento fabuloso sobre el mar
donde ese nenito que quería conocer
el mar le pide al padre que lo lleve.
El padre lo lleva.
Y cuando aparece el mar
en toda su inmensidad,
el niño, temblando, le toma
la mano al padre y le dice:
"¡Papá, papá, ayudame a mirar!".
La obligación de los adultos
es ayudar a mirar a la infancia,
porque el mundo es
muy complejo, es muy difícil.
Y no entra homeopáticamente
como en mi época
en que no había pantallas.
Hoy los chicos aprietan un botón
y les puede entrar el mundo
si nosotros no estamos ahí
filtrando y eligiendo por ellos.
Además de saldar
esa deuda con la infancia,
deseo profundamente que nos reencontremos,
que zurzamos esta grieta que nos separa
que no es más que el fruto
de la intolerancia frente al diferente,
al que piensa, al que siente,
al que sueña distinto que nosotros.
No merecemos que nos vengan
quitando humanidad.
Nos nos merecemos los "ismos"
de la posmodernidad:
el individualismo,
el egoísmo, el narcisismo,
el capitalismo, el consumismo,
el yaísmo, el ahorismo.
Todo eso nos resta humanidad.
Y Uds. me dirán cómo hacemos
para coser la grieta.
¿Con qué tipo de mirada?
Las miradas tienen que ser
amorosas, pacíficas, inclusivas.
"Pero, Liliana, nos acaba de decir
que no se pueden construir".
No, no se puede.
Pero si queremos tener miradas amorosas,
si queremos que nuestras miradas
acaricien al otro y no lo lastimen,
tenemos que trabajar
sobre nosotros mismos,
sobre nuestro propio mundo,
mirándonos, escuchando nuestro deseos,
viendo qué nos falta
hacer para ser felices.
Buscar esa felicidad,
buscar ese sueño frustrado,
esa asignatura pendiente,
trabajar los enojos,
rodearme de gente positiva
y, sobre todo, volver a esperanzarme.
Esa es una deuda
que tenemos con los adolescentes.
Si nos ven desesperanzados,
a ellos les va a costar mucho
armar un proyecto de vida.
Quisiera decir lo que decía
el "Nano" Serrat:
"Hoy puede ser un gran día",
para soltar la emoción,
para volver a comunicarnos,
para encontrarnos con la mirada.
No dejemos que las pantallas
hackeen los tiempos del amor.
De verdad, hoy puede ser un gran día
para volver a mirarnos.
Es la tarea.
(Aplausos)
(Ovación)